all right time for the daily hate on the
bootleg cev show celebrity edition his
new album comes out January 19th yes I
am sad go support it Fredo bang is here
Fredo what are you hating on I'm hating
on the on the fans cat fishes and some
of the celebrities who doing it if you
doing on fans and I subscribe to your
only fans I am coming to see you fully
fullblown naked bear busted open with a
little bit of play okay and little
touching little insertion and sexual
engagement okay if you're not doing that
you need to get get off of on the fans I
don't want to see you in your draws and
when I click the picture you got the you
got the thumbnail of you waving pulling
your draws down but when I hit when I go
to the picture it's just you talking to
me like are you the type of person who
will buy the messages to see I buy yeah
yeah so you you'll support I yeah I I
support our women okay so if you for
people who know there's there's such
thing as these messages a girl will
tease you yeah she give you the tease
and then and then you'll be like oh let
me let me give you $5 yeah spend $30 and
unlock the video and the video is
nothing yeah bro that's not right what's
the most you spent on only fans in a day
yeah I ain't going to lie
I be on anal I'll be
tripping I cuz you know you be focused
so i' been wait so you be jerking off
and only fans on the ad roll yeah God
bless it man about two three hours then
get the DM and everybody you used to
mess with as soon as you finish you like
man why it takes no well for also for
people who don't know for the most part
if you're going to follow celebrity on
only fans you're not seeing nothing like
if you're subscribing to cardi B's only
fans account you're just going to get
like a better version of her Instagram
yeah I Che yeah did you you subscribe to
cardis I subscribe to cardis I subscrib
to Ruby roses I subscribed to enchanting
I subscribed to uh Erica B Banks I
subscribe to Alexa Sky the double do
twins I just subscribe to all these
[__] I think uh you might have
a problem I didn't have a problem all
got
problems which celebrity has the best
page which how about this which fellow
rapper has the best page cuz Erica Banks
I feel like she flipped the switch got
the body done and she's looking like a a
different human being right now yeah um
best I ain't going lie the celebrity
they they
trash celebrities are trash they only
fans is trash it's hor Ruby roses isn't
great you're not seeing nothing new that
you haven't already seen on Instagram no
you get a little skin little skin a
little bit but I mean yeah you kind of I
wrote her about this too I say come on
bro did she know it was you hm did she
knew like no I wrote her on Twitter and
told her like hey hey I'm I'm $200 in
and I still ain't seen she did what I
didn't like she did a post talking about
cuz she had pink hair talking about pink
like my coocha hair I said well [__]
post uh put put a [__] amount
on on the fan so I can pay and see that
[__] I ain't seen that
[__] yet there it is ladies and
gentlemen Fredo bag he supports if you
only fans pop it off bro pop it off
don't come to play new album's coming
out on the 19th of January go support it
and let's get into your new record right
now I'm going let you introduce it man
my new record come through you hear man
come through